[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقه جديده مع
صديق الدكتور احمد فؤاد انور خبير الشان
الاسرائيلي
بنحاول من خلال الحوار معه ان نعرف ما
يجري داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي ماذا يقولون
عن الحرب الدائره في غز خطتهم لغزه
تصوراتهم لمسار الحرب مدى قبول او رفض
المجتمع الاسرائيلي لما يجري مساء الخير
معالي الدكتور مساء الخير سيد بيه وتحياتي
داوم ربنا يخليك ويسعدك انا عاوز اسال
حضرتك سؤالين معالي الدكتور سؤال يتعلق
بحجم الخسائر الحقيقيه في الجانب
الاسرائيلي هل الارقام اللي بتعلن اسرائيل
واللي هي كانت حتى امس اللي هو 12 نوفمبر
2023 اظن 45 قتيل هل هي ارقام دقيقه ولا
في احتمال ان يكون فيها تلاعب لان في
تضارب بين الارقام الاسرائيليه والارقام
التي تعلنها المقاومه يعني طبعا الارقام
بيتم ضغطها بمعنى ان بيتم توزيعها بمعنى
تقليل الصدمه على الجانب الاسرائيلي اولا
في رقيب عسكري بيبقى في صيغه ان تم السماح
بنش بان سقط اثنين من الكوماندوز النهارده
سقط اربعه من الوحدات الخاصه لاحظ حضرتك
ان الاغلبيه ب من الوحدات عاليه التدريب
بيتم الافصاح بالتدريج او بالتمهيد ان في
اربع اصابات في حاله حرجه بعد كده بيتم
الاعلان عن الوفاه وعاده بيكون لابلاغ
الاسره اولا فده امر الامر الثاني ان هم
بيتجاهل ان يوم 7عه كان في في حدود فوق ال
1400 عسكريين ومدنيين حسبه التوصيف
الاسرائيلي رغم ان بعضهم كان بيبقى معاه
طبنجات و 55 طلقه او ان هو من قوات
الاحتياط فيسمح له بالعوده برشاش الى
المنزل فهذا صحيح ان كلمه مدنيين دي كلمه
مش دقيقه قوي لان كثير منهم يعني بيحمل
السلاح احتياط ا قوات الاحتياط فادي جزء
الجزء الثاني ان في حالات بيتم توزيعها ان
دول في الشمال فلا يتم حسابهم حزب الله
والاشتباكات اسفرت عن سقوط خسائر اعتر بها
الجانب الاسرائيلي لكنه لا يحصيهم ا من
خسائر غزه من خسائر الصدام او المواجهه
الحاجه الثانيه ان في ناس ينسب ان هم
قتلوا وهم في طريقهم الى منزلهم في الضفه
ضابط مثلا ان في اشتباكات مع مهربين
بالصدفه في نفس التوقيت مع مصر مع مصر
فبالتالي بيتم توزيع الصدمه لكن على على
الراي العام الداخلي بالدرجه الاول اه
ولاحظ حضرتك حاجتين ان الاليات لا يتم
الاعلان ابدا ان في اليه تضررت اللي هي
المدرعات الدبابات مدرعات مصفحات مروحيات
ميارات ما فيش خساير يعني الجانب الغزاوي
طلع الحمساوي الفصائل المقاومه
طلع يعني فيديو موثق لاكثر من حاله بيتم
استهداف فيها هذه المضارعات وقال انا وثقت
160 اليه ده احدث رقم فبالتالي الرقم لا
يتواكب مع يعني داخل الال اكيد
في خسائر بشريه فهو نوع من التكميم
الافواه من الجانب الاسرائيلي لان الناس
اللي كانوا مسندين بالكامل او يلا معا
سننتصر قالوا له احنا مش عايزين خساير من
داخل اسرائيل اللي كانوا متحمسين للعمليه
العسكريه لما لو زادت الارقام ممكن
يتراجعوا اه اولا احنا ما بنحضرش
المحتجزين فين الهدف الاولويه ان انا اطلع
الناس الاولويه مش واضحه او مافيش في
قدرتي ان انا احققها الا بالتفاوض
فبالتالي كمان بخسر يعني قوات كوماندوز
عنده المتوسط يا السيد 22 سنه يعني واحد
عنده 74 سنه بيبعت الناس لغزه عشان يحرروا
ناس بدل ما بيحرم بيموتوا عندهم 22 سنه
فده في العقل الجامعي الاسرائيلي بيبقى
ضاغط على على نتنياهو ان هو ما كانش من
اهدافه اصلا تحرير المحتجزين هو من اهدافه
التخلص من الكتله السكانيه دي اذا فانت
بتقول لنا ان الارقام اللي بتعلن هي في
الغالب فيها هي بيتم فلط فلترتها بحيث ان
هي تبدو اخف من الحقيقه صحيح صحيح اما ان
هو بيحسبها تحت فئات مختلفه ده تم يوم 7عه
لا ده تم منذ بدء العمليه البريه ده تم في
الشمال ده تم ده تم الى اخره طيب ما لا
يتم الاعلان
المصابين بيتم تهميش ولا اليات خالص ولا
اليات طيب في نوع اني من الخساير وانت
مهتم بيه اللي هو خساير الحرب اللي هي في
شكل بقى احنا طبعا على الجانب الاقتصادي
اتكلمنا في نعرف اقتصاد كتير واتكلمت مع
حضرتك لكن كمان في ك نعرف اقتصاد بنتكلم
تقريبا كل اسبوع عن الخساره الاقتصاديه
لكن انت الخساير اللي هي مجتمعيه شويه على
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ابرزها ايه وو ابرزها
طبعا ان في
غياب الامن انا دلوقتي كنتت في غلاف غزه
وتحلت ليلات اه وده مش معتاد يعني المفترض
انزل المخب خليك في المخب انما سيب غلاف
غزه بالكامل وانزل على ايلات وهعمل لك
خيام طبعا ده يعني مشاهد غير مسبوقه ومش
متعودين على كده وماجوش عشان كده اه هم
قالوا ماجوش من اوكرانيا وماجوش من من بره
يقوللك انا يهودي لا يقوللك داين يقوله لا
انت مشكوك في يهديك انت مش يهودي انت جاي
لاسباب اقتصاديه واحنا فعلا هنديلك كل ما
تقرب من غزه هنديك مبلغ كل سنه الحكومه
الاسيه تطلع لك 200000 شيكل عشان انت على
بعد 10 كيلو من غز بدل مخاطره بدل مخاطره
ممكن فدي انا جاي عشان كده انما مش عشان
اموت فراح ايلات لا برض في مسيرات وفي
حاجات في فناء من مدرسه سقطت مصيره
وانفجرت هو لم تسقطها القبه الحديديه
فبالتالي في في الشمال
فبالمال
واحد في في الشمال
سابوا ونزلوا على تل ابيب رشقات مستمره
على تل ابيب انا دلوقتي دخلت بري ودخلنا
في الشهر الثاني ايه الانجاز يعني ففي
مذيع اسرائيلي قال لن في المستقبل لن
تتحقق لنا صوره نصر صوره نصر ان انت يبقى
عندك
اه السنوار طالع مستسلم بعالم ابيض تم
تصفيه كل القيادات تم التحرير الرهائن في
زمن قياسي الرئ او المحتجزين والاسر فده
مش مش هيحصل مش مش ما حصلش المذيع ده في
التلفزيون الرسمي فقال كده وقال احنا
بالفعل خسرنا الحرب فالاحساس ده والراجل
وزير التراس كان بيتكلم على قنبله ذريه
لانه مش شايف في امكانيه في المستقبل ان
احنا
نحقق الاهداف هل في عدد كبير من
الاسرائيليين صحيح يغادر اسرائيل ام ان
هذه مبالغات في الصحف العربيه لا مش في
الصحف العربيه لغايه 1 نوفمبر رسميا 23000
اضيف لهم بقى ال 200000 الداخلي كانه
بيقول لك القلب في اسرائيل لكن الجسد في
الطياره 230 ال غدر اسرائيلي غادره الى
الى خارج اسرائيل اه انا مش انا مش جاي
عشان الحكايه دي
اه انا اولا الردع
ده من اسس قيام اسرائيل اضرب بمعنى ان انا
مش هضرب طلقه بس الناس عارفه قوتي فمش
هتضربني ده كانت الفكره اللي اسرائيل
بتتبعها كاستراتيجيه بالضبط فهو الفكره
دلوقتي دي تعرضت لطمه ومهانه ان قائد لواء
غزه يتم اسه ان اقتحام الفرقه مقر قياده
الفرقه ان مافيش مخابرات تحذر ان الج اللي
انا صرفت عليه 3 مليار دولار يا نهار كده
والناس تخش بموتوسيكل وجراف في وضح النهار
ان في عندي منطاد بيصور لم يستطع يعني ان
هو سلاح الجو فين ففي 200000 واحد
230 وفي نازحين بقى او مهجرين داخليا
200000 اه فدول عايزين تعويضات بيجي
الميعاد في اول الشهر فين المرتب طب انا
عندي سؤال
تاني المقاومه في كلام كتير كه عن مصادر
تسلحه
ا هل في صوره واضحه قاريت اطلعت حد من
مصادرك المباشره المطلعين سواء فلسطينيين
او مصادر غير فلسطينيه يعني بتقول من اين
تاتي المقاومه بهذا السلاح هو طبعا
وفق المصادر العبريه نفسها السلاح بيتم
صدقته بشكل يومي من الجيش الاسرائيلي
بمعنى ان تلاقي النهارده حاله الطقس اسعار
العمله وعدد من الذخيره طلع واتسرق احنا
فقد في التدريب في صناديق كذا القنابل كذا
بشكل يعني ده ده في السنوات يعني منذ
سنوات ا على مدار السنوات ده بيتم بيعه
للفصائل
مباشره او عبر وسطاء مقابل فلوس او مخدرات
من يسرق السلاح من الجيش الاسرائيلي هم
اسرائيليون اه طبعا و ممكن يكون من داخل
الجيش مثلا هو من الجيش من المجندين ومن
الضباط
بيع ب فقد بيقول فقد او سرق عظم اه ودول
بياخدوا السلاح لاغراض منها البيون الزبون
في غزه ما فيش زبون غير في غزه بال
الكميات لان انا ممكن ابيع للعصابات اللي
هو الجريمه المنظمه في اسرائيل برده
مزدهره وفيها اللي هي مناطق نفوذ داخل ال
48 بس استهلاكها في السلاح تاخد قنبله كل
سنه قنبلتين نايم فبضطر فعلا ان هو ايه
يعمل اللي بيسموه عرض خاص اه خذوا صندوقين
ذخيره وفي الكلام ده بيتنشر وبيتكتب اه
طبعا بال عتاد يعني ممكن يديه الام 16 معه
الخوزه اللي ضد الدخان او ضد كذا او قنابل
اضاءه لا لا كميات يعني فده مورد المورد
الثاني كان ده مصدر من مصادر السلاح هو
الشراء عن طريق لهم تجار السلاح اللي هم
غالبا بيسرقوا من الجيش الاسرائيلي اللي
هم الضباط نفسهم بيبيعوا مباشره او عبر
وسطاء طبعا هدفه الاساسي هو الربح اه طبعا
اه فده جزء فهو والموضوع ده قديم يقول لك
احنا بنضرب من حزب الله بصواريخها بحاجتنا
يعني دي اللي بيسقط علينا ده شغلنا ده
فكان من زمان هي الحكايه دي مش جديده فهم
اخلاقيا ما عندوش هذهه بضاعتنا ردت
الينا جزء مصدر مهماني اساسي اللي هو
الورش التصنيع المحلي والتطوير وده بيبص
على النت او بيقابل ناس بره او
بيجيله عبر
الانفاق خبراء يدربو على التصنيع والتطوير
بقى كل شويه يحاول يطور ده اللي عاده
المقاومه بتقول ان مصدر تدريبي وصلح لي لو
انا كنت مخطئ ان هو ايران بالدرجه الاولى
او حزب الله اللي هو حليف ايران انه ياتي
مهندسين من ايران او من حزب الله او ناس
خبراء فيه وبيساعد توهم في تطوير نماذج
اللي هي الصواريخ كده لا سليم كلام دقيق
فهو الفكره ان في تصنيع محلي بيتطور مع
الوقت ومع التجارب ا وبيبقى في حدود ال
5000 صاروخ في اليوم يتم اطلاقهم على
الجانب الاسرائيلي ففي زخم في ترسانه يعني
فده امر الامر الثاني ان المصدر الثالث
بقى المصدر الثالث كان رئيس صدام حسين
وعمل يعني
ا يعني صيغه للمساعده ان انا هديكم
الاسلحه الايرانيه التي استطعت ان احصل
على عليها واستولت عليها اثناء حرب الخليج
اثناء حرب ضد ايران اللي هي من سنه 80
لسنه 88 كانت بعض الاسلحه الايرانيه تسقط
في يد القوات مواقع جواء اسلحه
يتم اسرها تم الحصول عليها ف هو جمعهم
وقال لي يا س عرفات انا صلهم لك لليمن انت
من اليمن توصلهم لغزه وبالفعل تمت الحكايه
دي على مراحل
ا عبر الانفاق الانفاق يعني كان في فتره
كده اللي بيسموها ايه غض النظر طبعا اذا
كان مصر بده غض النظر فالجانب الاصالي فين
اه اه فكان الرئيس مبارك يا الله يرحمه
كان يقول لك النفق ما ليه فتحتين اه كير
سد من عندك اه كتير بس هل ممكن اسالك عن
مصدر المعلومه المعلومه دي انا ما قريتش
في اي مصدر اه ده احد مستشار الرئيس عرفات
انا طبعا ما استاذنت توش في ان انا اقول
اسمه انما ا دي معلومه انا اثق في الشخصيه
ديت وفي لاعها مسؤول مسؤول فلسطيني اه
مسؤول فلسطيني بارز عظيم جدا طيب ده يبقى
اذا المصدر الثالث هي اسلحه ايرانيه وقعت
في ايدي القوات العراقيه وارسلها صدام الى
ياسر عرفات عن طريق اليمن تمام في مصدر
كمان اسرائيل سمحت ب 00000 بندقيه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه داخل غزه السلطه الفلسطينيه
وجدت ان حماس تطل براسها داخل غزه ده قبل
2007 اه بالضبط بتطل براسها داخل غزه
وابتدت يبقى في مناوشات في حديث عن قلاقل
احتمال كذا فالسلطان هي برض بموافقه
الجانب الاسرائيلي دخلت مضرعات قوه 17 وده
مصدر فلسطيني داخل القوه
17 اه قيادي داخل هذه القوه كان في حاجه
اسمها الامن الوقائي الامن الوقائي برض
ليه ثقه له بس القوه 17 في مسا ف بينها من
حيث القوه والافضليه والامكانيات هذه
الاسلحه وفق
المصدر اللي داخل هذه القوه قال لي وصلت
سليمه الحماس يعني لم تشتبك في في قمع
المحاولات الاستلاء السلطه او السيطره على
قطاع غزه ووصلت سليمه الى ممكن ل في
الانفاق يعني باختصار انه قبل 2007 حين
كانت السلطه اللي هي منظمه التحرير او
منظمه فتح تح تحديدا والرئيس محمود محمود
عباس ابو مازن كان موجود هو تم تسليحه
باسلحه قادره على بسط الامن الداخلي
وخصوصا في مواجهه الجماعات المسلحه زي
حماس والجهاد صحيح صحيح لما حصل انه حماس
في صدامها مع السلطه في 2006 و27 واخرجت
السلطه من من غزه اخذت هذه الاسلحه بالب
كده بر بالضبط اه في وقعه ثانيه ممكن
الاشاره اليها اللي هو جيش القذافي بعد
سقوط القذافي ايوه بعد سقوط القذافي ابتدت
الاسلحه تباع طبعا وكان برض في حاله سيوله
في مصر كده وانشغال وانكفاء على امور اخرى
فبدات الاسلحه تتسرب عبر الانفاق وسيد
حضرتك قدر مني يعني او مطلع كويس جدا على
موضوع الانفاق ان الناس بتعمل في الانفاق
انا اذكر جيدا يمكن كنت بقول لك قبل ما ما
نسجل انه انا في
2013 ان حضرك اه ده انا بقول انا حابب
اروح غزه حقيقي بمنتهى البساطه لينا زميله
ويعني يمكن هي سامعاني دلوقتي راحت مطلعه
نوت صغيره كده وقالت لي انا معايا سبعه
انفاء يعني اصحاب لانفاق في سينا وانا
بتعامل معاهم هي كصحفي يعني اي فقالت لي
انا اكلم لك ده انا بثق فيه وكانت المساله
ميسوره جدا اه جدا وبعد كده بقيت القصه
بقى طويله مش عاوز اشغل بها الناس ولكن
فجئت لما انا بكلم اصحابي وجدت انه عندهم
عروض اخرى لسهوله الدخول فكانت احنا طبعا
عنينا لفتره من الموضوع ده لان هو بيتاجر
باليوم بمعنى انت بقى عايز تهرب بشر عاوز
تهرب مخدرات سلع تموينيه اسلحه مالكش دعوه
انا اجرته منك باليوم هل في اي مصدر خام
ولا هو دي كل المصادر اللي هي عند
المقاومه لا هي دي المصادر الاساسيه بس
طبعا في محاولات التهريب عبر البحر برض
عبر البحر هناك
محاولات للتهريب فده حوالي 50 ال عنصر
مقاوم ومعاهم ترسانه من الاسلحه اغلبها
يعني مضاده للدروع او محاولات كده لتطوير
الاسلحه الخاصه بالقسام اللي هي صواريخ
القسام كانت في البدايه كتيوشه هاون اصبحت
الان تصل الى حيفا وده طبعا مؤشر خطر
ويجعل اسرائيل تستخدم مقلاع داوود اللي هو
تسعه اضعاف تكلفه القبه الحديه هل نتنياهو
عنده خطه واضحه لاداره قطاع غزه ان تمكن
اصلا من تحقيق حلمه في السيطره واسكات
المقاومه هل عنده خطه واضحه اجابه مختصره
يعني احنا كل يوم بنسمع عن حاجه بس بنسمع
من حاجه مصادر امريكيه لا مصادر مش عارف
اسرائيليه رئيس الوزراء نفسه هل لديه خطه
واضحه لمست ققبل غزه ان تمكن من اسكات
المعارضه ما هو من اسكات المقاومه اه هو
طبعا البديل الاول ليه ان هو يشرف بنفسه
على القطاع ويحتل القطاع ان هو بعد كده
البديل الثاني ان هو يستعين بعناصر
فلسطينيه تقود يعني الحديث مثلا عن
انتخابات محمود عباس ابو مازن يسلم لمروان
غوتي
مثلا يعاونه محمد دحلان او ان المجموعه ده
بيتقال اه بيتقال يتردد يعني ان الناس
تيجي تشرف على القطاع تدير فده محتاج اولا
زي ما اقول حضرتك كده ارضيه موافقه
مسانده للعناصر الفلسطينيه اه انما محمود
عباس ابو مازن ضعيف اضفته اسرائيل الامر
ده السيد يحتاج الى شيء كبير عشان تمريره
الشيء الكبير ده تديني حاجه في القدس انا
محمد دحلان اللي جبت لكم حاجه في القدس
انا مروان برغوت اللي انقذت لكم الضفه من
الضياع بعد ما كانت ال كانتونات غير كده
هيتم استهدافه
من العناصر الفلسطينيه المناوئه وهتبقى
الدايره تتسع طوال الوقت يعني هو الفكره
كده انت تقصد ان ايا كان الكادر الفلسطيني
او اسمه اللي هيجي ما يقدرش يدخل غزه الا
اذا جاء بانجاز كبير يشفع له ويخليه يبقى
وجه مقبول بالضبط كده في غزه وخارج غزه اه
انما الحل الغزاوي فقط ده قصر نظر وتم
تجريبه منقابل هو الراجل احيانا عنده اللي
انا ما يترجم في اللغه الانجليزيه
والعربيه انه عنده تناقد هل التناقض ده
سوء ترجمه ولا هو فعلا متناقض نتنياهو لما
بيتكلم عن مستقبل غزه لا لا هو في نفس
اليوم بيسال فيقول حاجتين متناقضين فرق
ساعات بين الاجابه دي والاجابه دي هو
مشكلته ان هو مستني على الميدان اللي
هيحصل اه لو في السنوار سقط واستسلم اللي
هو رئيس حركه حماس او رئيس المكتب السياسي
يعني اه ان انما لو العكس ان حماس استطاعت
تفريغ السجون الاسرائيليه من اطفال من
نساء من كل المبادله في اه فهو محتجزين
اداريين محتجزين امنيين انت بتتكلموا يا
عالم يا مره في الحس يادافع حقوق الانسان
عن مدنيين ورهاء اسرائيليين طب ما في
اطفال محتجزين لدى في السجون الاسرائيليه
منذ سنوات في نساء حماه حماس هي اللي لفتت
الانتباه لده والحديث ان بالفعل سيتم
الافراج عنه فده هيدي افضليه لحماس ويجعل
الاوراق تتبعثر ان لا ده انا هضطر اتفاوض
مع حماس لا ده انا هضطر الفتره الانتقاليه
اشرك فيها حماس فده بيقلب الطاوله فوق
السيناريو المفضل السيناريو المفضل ان هو
يتخلص من السكان او ان حد يجي يدير هيجي
يدير في مقابل ايه هل سيتم مقاوم مقاومته
هل ست تتاجج الامور اكث فالجانب
الاسرائيلي الراي العام الداخلي بيقول كل
الحرب دي لا تخدم سوا اسره واحده فاسده ب
ساره نتنياهو وابنها يائير
و الفاشل امنيا والفاسد بامتياز
الديكتاتور بيبي نتنياهو طب قبل ما اسالك
عن ان الحرب دي بتخدم اسره واحده هو انا
مش قادر اصدق ان هذا الرجل بكل يعني خبرته
كان بيراهن على واحد انه يعتقد ان كان
هيحصل قبول لتفريق سكان غزه وان مصر
هترحبو يعني اثنين انه كان يعتقد ويراهن
على انه هجد فلسطينيين جاهزين لقبول
المهمه لاداره غزه ده في حاله ان هو اصلا
نجح في اسكات المقاومه دي مهمه مش مضمونه
كان بيران ان هو يهجد ده بسهوله بدون ما
يقدم لهم اي حلول او اي انجازات ولا اي
حاجه هيوافقوا بسهوله واهل غزه هيرحب بيه
هل كان بيراهن على انه الول عربيه ممكن
تلعب دور قوات حفظ سلام ولا اداره لان
الكلام ده اطرح برض دول عربيه هل هل يعقل
ان الناس بهذه الخبارات والذكاء كانت
تعتقد ان الحلول دي ممكنه وهنوا عليها في
خطه هو المشكله الاساسيه ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي مش جاهز يعني هو بيسته دف
عمارات
بيسته مدني مستشفيات فبالتالي كان من
المامول لدى نتنياهو ان هو الجيش هينقذ
ويحرر هائ او المحتجزين
ويصور انتصرنا انما مش والولايات المتحده
تساند دلوقتي الغرب بيبتدي يتراجع ماكرون
ابتدى يقول تصريحات مناوه ابتدى يتكلم على
ان لا المدنيين مسؤوليه الجانب الاسرائيلي
فابتدا المظاهرات الحاشده في لندن فده
بيدي مؤشر شر سلبي داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي اللي كان عينه على 57 ودوله
شاركت في قمه في السعوديه وخاصه اللقطه
بتاعه التقارب السعودي الايراني انا
هستاذنك هسالك عن القمه ارجع بقى للتعبير
اللي هو مثير للدهشه انه صحفي ولا كاتب
ولا مسؤول سابق قال ان حرب غزه هي لخدمه
اسره واحده اللي هو بيبي نتنياهو واسرته
بالبط وخصوصا مراته اللي بيقولوا ان هي
ليها دور في اداره شؤون الدول ايوه وابنه
يائير ياير اللي هو دلوقتي موجود في
الولايات المتحده تمام اه هم بيعتقدوا ان
الحرب دي لخدمتهم بمعنى ام بمعنى ان هذا
شخص فاسد تلحقه اتهامات بالفساد احتشد ضده
معسكر هو اسمه معسكر لال لنتنياهو
فزاد فوق كل هذا فشله الامني في 7 اكتوبر
في 7 اكتوبر ان على يديه دم هم هو المسؤول
عن دم الذين سقطوا فبالتالي يجب ان يزح
الان لانه خطر على دوله اسرائيل لا يجب
الانتظار الى ما بعد الحرب هو يقول لا
ادوني فرصه انا وزير دفاعي هنست طيع ان
احنا نحقق النص واعداء اسرائيل طبعا ده
فصيل محاصر بقله 17 سنه يعتبر اصبع في
كف جسد المقاومه اه كلها الفلسطينيه كلها
لا الجسد المقاومه اللي هو محور المقاومه
حزب الله ايران حزب ايران قه ده ايران
عندها نواوي ده هنعمل ايه مع ايران اذا
كنت انت دخلت بنا الشهر الثاني ولم تحقق
الا انجاز ولا انجاز واحد فبالتالي هذا
الامر
هو السائد في اسرائيل بيقولوا احنا بنقول
للراي العام العالمي ولا يستجاب لنا يعني
بمعنى ان كان في سفيره في جنوب افريقيا
بتقول انا بفتكر الايام اللي كانت كنت
فيها وكانت في انتفاضه وقول لهم الارهاب و
ماتوا في عمليات يقولوا انتم زي جنوب
افريقيا العنصريه انتم نظام بريتوريا
العنصريه واللي بتتعرض ليه تستحق الناس
اللي بيقولوا ان هذه الحرب من اجل اسره
واحده يقصدوا انه نتنياهو بيطي امد الحرب
ا املا اولا في ان يظل فييه السلطه لانه
طالما قائد في حاله حرب عاده بؤج الحسابات
الى حين انته الحرب صحيح صحيح فكلما طالت
الحرب كلما طال امد بقاؤه في السلطه صحيح
ثم انه يامل لو قدر يحقق انجاز ان هذا
الانجاز قد يشفع له عند الراي العام
الاسرائيلي فيغفر له ا يعني تقصيره واذا
غفر له تقصيره هيفضل في السلطه فيقدر
يحاول يتنصل من جرائم الفساد التي تطارده
مظبوط كده يا دكتور صحيح صحيح هو بس لو
تسمح لي هم حاليا بيقولوا فيتنام بيفكروا
بفيتنام ان انتم بتراهن كجنرال على تسويء
الحرب ان احنا ماشيين كو كويس بان عدد
الضحايا الناحيه الثانيه سقط من الجانب
الاق ده مش انجاز ونفس الخطه دي عملتها
امريكا والجيش الامريكي في فيتنام وثبت
فشلها فبيقول ان الافق مظلم ان احنا
ماشيين غلط انت حراك بتقول انه لما وجه
التشبيه في فيتنام ان الجنرالات
الاسرائيليين بيف خروا بالاعداد الكبيره
من الضحايا في الجانب الفلسطيني زي ما
الامريكان كانوا بيتحدث عن الخسائر الكبير
اللي بيلحقوه في الجانب الفيتنامي صحيح
فبعض الاسرائيليين او الكتاب بيقولوا هذا
مؤشر خطر ده مش معناه ان احنا انتصرنا
بيقول ان لا ده مش معيار انتصار بالعكس ده
هنكرر الفعله بتاعه فيتنام ان زي ما خسر
هو بيبرر طيله الوقت بان انا يا جماعه
بقتل اهو في الناس والاعداد بتزيد فاصبروا
علينا شويه و قال له ده مش الانجاز فين
الانجاز انت كده ماشي على خط فيتنام
وجنرالات امريكا فيتنام كانوا بيشتغلوا
بنفس الخط ده ما عشان يقول انجاز لازم
يحدد اهداف محدده وهدف رقم واحد هو عنده
اسرى اللي هم عسكريين صح وعنده محتجزين او
رهائن زي ما بيسموهم البعض اللي هم
المدنيين فالهدف الاولاني استعاده
المدنيين ثم التفاوض على العسكريين ان لم
يكن تحريرهم بالبط اثنين هو بيقول الهدف
الثاني والمعلن ضرب كل حركات
المقاومه بما ان الاهداف ديت لم تتحقق حتى
الان فبد ان يقولوا له ان انت تقتل اكبر
عدد من الاطفال او من المدنيين او من
الاطباء ده مش انجاز يعني بالضبط اه فهو
ده المشكله والازمه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
ان احنا بننزف ان احنا لسه بنتعرض لخسائر
داخل غزه ورشقات مستمره وما فيش انجاز
والاقتصاد مشلول وطبعا حضرتك عارف صورتنا
قدام العالم العالم ابتدت النبره صورتنا
صورتهم كا
اسرائيليين كلموه هو بيقوله انت دلوقتي مع
الوقت المظاهرات بتزيد الضغوط على العواصم
بتزيد النبره بتاع وشنطن نفسها بتختلف فده
ضاغط على الجانب الاسرائيلي وخلاه يعني
يعني يطالب الجانب الرسمي باعاده تقييم
وانا اعتقد ان حكومه الطوارئ كانت تقوم
على ايزن كوت رئيس اركان سابق على بيني
جانتس وزير الدفاع سابق وعلى يوف جالانت
ونتنياهو
ان كانت الصلاحيات فيها تضارب ان كده كتير
فابتدع لا احنا هنكت بثلاثه نتنياهو وبيني
جانتس و ويف جلان اتضح ان ده من جوه في
انشقاق ان في اثنين راحوا على جنب
الجنرالات طبعا راحوا في الجنب وسابوا
بيبي اللي هو دماغه في لجنه تحقيق يعني
انا دلوقتي لما باجي اكتب مذكراتي بقول
اللي كان مفترض اقوله هو دلوقتي بيفكر
باللي المفروض يقول ويبرر قدام لجنه
التحقيق وازاي تشكل ومين اللي هي شكلها
وصلاحياتها ايه فده عامل ضغط على ده زائد
الانجازات على الارض الغائبه ان مافيش
انجازات للجيش الاسرائيلي الذي يتحدث
الكثيرين يعني في الخارج عن انه نمر من
ورق انه من حرب 67 من حرب 73 وهو جيش من
الجبناء ده مؤرخ اسرائيلي اللي بيقول دخل
في فشل الى فشل الى فشل في الانتفاضه
هو يعني طبعا ا يعني انا مندهش ان هو داخل
اسرائيل بيقولوا كده لكن انا هو اذا
استعرض ده فعلا بيقول اكثر من كده بيقول
رئيس الاركان راجل زي قصه بيه يتجمل ده
اديب عايز يهرب من من المحاكمه فبيعمل في
صوره الروايه فما قالش رئيس اركان معين
انما عايز الفت نظر حضرتك ان شرعيه
اسرائيل هو الجيش ده جيش الاحتلال وجداره
القوى العسكريه وليس ليس اي جداره قانونيه
ولا تاريخيه هي التي تجعل فلما اول مره
يتجرا هو ممكن يمسك في وزير الدفاع وزير
دفاع سياسي اه انما رئيس الاركان هو راس
الهرم الفعلي وليه هيبه ومن من مش من
النادر هذه سبقه خطيره ان يتجرا المجتمع
الاسي يتجرا على انتقاد رئيس قص باليو
تتجمل وبتنزل شعر روائي الان بينتقد في
روايه العسكريين الاسرائيل نير روايه حي
لها حرون اللي هو الجندي الاخير اه طبعا
بيقول ان في فصدرت امتى يا دكتور دي من
اربع سنين اه هو هو يعتبر روائي شاب ومؤثر
وبالتالي بيتكلم بجراءه عن ان في فساد في
جيش الاحتلال ان التدريب ده تدريب مضحك
وان النماذج اللي جوه دي فاشله وان الضباط
دول عندهم عقد نفسيه تجاه الفلسطينيين حتى
الاعزم اللي هو مش مصدر خطر وان ده بيخلي
الاطفال الفلسطينيين اللي بيبصوا علينا من
القريه المجاوره بفضول لا خلاص حدد موقفه
انت بتخوف جدي انت حاطط الرشاش بدون اي
مبرر داخل العربيه انت معطلنا سبع ساعات
ممان ساعات فده بيخلي احنا في شغلنا او
بنحش مصدر خطر ما فيش مصدر فبالتالي هو
بيوجه اصبع اتهام للجيش ده بانه يسير في
مسار خاطئ ده الروايه دي كانت واضح ان هي
سابقه وقتها يعني لان هي استشرفت ان الجيش
اللي هو بيقو راقصه باليه ده لازم ممكن
يخسر خساره كبيره هو ايه رد الفعل
الاسرائيلي باختصار شديد على القمه
العربيه الاسلاميه اللي عقدت في الرياض في
11 نوفمبر الجاري هو طبعا الحدث الرئيسي
التطبيع السعودي الايراني الذي يسير على
دلوقتي على مستوى القمه
في مقابله
وفي صور علنيه فده كان استوقف الجانب
الاسرائيلي بين الرئيس الايراني وولي
العهد السعودي بالضبط وفي 57 مجرد ان 57
التقوا 57 زعيم دول 50 دوله التق الحاجه
الثانيه ان بيقولوا لا هو ما فيش
قرارات تنفيذيه يعني في ادانه في رفض
للتهجير القصري في دعم لمصر انما على
الارض مافيش قرارات عمليه مؤثره يعني
سلطنه عمان مثلا بشكل انفراضي قبل القمه
قالت ممنوع الطيران يعدي من الطيران
الاسرائيلي يعدي من الاجواء طبعا هما
الجانب الاسرائيلي استبق القمه
واستبق الاحداث دي بان هو سحب طاقم
السفاره من كل الدول المرشحه انها تطرد
السفير لان كان في وقع قبل كده في تركيا
ان تم طرد السفير صوير ده بشكل مهين فده
اسبقو بان هم سحبوا بدواعي امنيه علشان ما
يتعرضو لاحراج طرد
سفرهم او يعني اخراجه من البلد بالضبط كده
فهو ده الامور اللي بيتكلموا فيها ان ان
في تطبيع مع السعوديه تجمد ان كان في مسار
تطبيع شبه علني وان ملامحه بدات تتضح ان
ده دهده يعني دخل الى التلاجه زي ما
بيقولوا فاكثر ما اقلق في القمه هو وجود
ادانه من 57 حتى لو لم تكن الادانه ديت
تحمل خطوات وان محور المقاومه يمكن ان
ينسق او يمكن ان يجد ارضيه مشتركه مع محور
الاعتدال جزيل الشكر معال الدكتور تحياتي
سيد شكرا جدا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم في حلقات
اخرى باذن الله